[music]
The Islamic connection is the name of
this lecture
and it's quite a story.
The Islamic religion is huge today and
it has some very fascinating features.
It's a very exclusive religion. Nobody
from the outside is allowed in. If there
are pilgrimages to Mecca, only those of
the Islamic faith are allowed to go to
these pilgrimages. It is an exclusive
religion. Evangelism in Islamic
countries is totally forbidden.
This religion has full control of the
entire territory which it controls. Now
who and what is Islam?
Now I have known many people from the
Islamic faith. As a professor at the
university, many of my students were of
the Islamic faith and I can tell you
that I have very high regard for them.
They are conscientious. They are serious
about their faith. They believe that
they are doing the right thing. They
have a very high standard of what is
right and what is wrong and they will
stand for principle. These are all
wonderful ideals by those propagating
the Islamic faith. and they are loyal
like no others. Of all my students, I
can honestly say that the students that
came from the Islamic faith were loyal
beyond anything that I could mention.
So let me pay tribute to them. You will
remember that we in the lectures
discussed that the Knights Templars had
two
aspects of their religion. The one was
for the goyam for the uninitiated
and that according to morals and dogma
and all the the testimonies relating to
this issue was Catholicism. So the
outside world got Catholicism. the inner
esoteric circle had luciferianism.
That was what happened in Catholicism.
Do you think it might be possible
that exactly the same thing could be
happening in the Islamic faith? That
there is an inner circle and an outer
circle that the inner circle has one
faith and the outer circle gets guam
religion the Islamic faith and that
controlling them both is a central
organization
which is seated where? Well, the Bible
says that it is seated in Rome and
nowhere else. The Bible says that the
beast is
Roman.
It comes out of the Roman Empire and
Islam does not come out of the Roman
Empire. The controlling force in the
Bible is Rome. This is an interesting
point. So if we look at this tremendous
rival religion which in numbers equals
Catholicism, what is its origin and why
is it there? These are very important
questions. This is a mighty mighty
religion
and millions of people make the
pilgrimages to Mecca where they worship
at the shrine of Muhammad.
What a privilege it is for them to make
the pilgrimage. There's another religion
which also propagates pilgrimages and
that is Catholicism.
So you have pilgrimages to lur and the
Marian sites and to Fatima.
Pilgrimage is a symbol of the great
pagan religions of the past as well. Now
who was Muhammad? Muhammad Mustafa was
born in 570 AD and he died in 632 AD. He
fled to Medina in 622 AD after Kadia's
death. Now who was Kadijah? Muhammad
married Kajida when he was 25 and she
was 40 years old. Her cousin Varaka was
a Roman Catholic and she came from a
Roman Catholic convent. So we could say
she was a Roman Catholic nun.
She was super rich. She lived in a
convent and she had um
the whole of the economy basically in
her hand and she employed this young man
Muhammad whom she then also married.
Muhammad marched on Mecca in 630 AD two
years before he died and four years
before Omar became Khalif. And the Quran
was compiled in 650 A. And Muhammad who
couldn't write himself had a scribe to
write down what he saw and what he
heard. And the Quran is different
apparently from all other religious
writings because it was a directly
dictated book.
So it is not just transcribed by a
prophet. So they teach but is the very
word of God and therefore it must always
remain in its original Arabic language.
That is what is taught in the Islamic
religion. The symbol of Islam is the
sickle moon and the star. The star
within the sickle moon. Now where does
this symbol come from?
And who is Allah? Well, let's go to uh
some interesting quotes also from
encyclopedias of religion and etc.
Allah. He was the moon god who married
the sun goddess. Together they produced
three goddesses who were called the
daughters of Allah. These three
goddesses were called alat, al- uza and
manat.
The encyclopedia of religion mentions
that Allah is a pre-Islamic name
corresponding to the Babylonian bell.
Fascinating.
So this is an ancient pagan religion and
ba or bal is the deity.
We read in morals and dogma page 451 the
Arabian word al dearan means the
foremost or leading star and it could
only have been so named when it did
precede or lead all others. The year
then opened with the sun in Taurus and
the multitude of ancient sculptures both
in Assyria and Egypt wherein the bull
appears with lunette or crescent horns
and the disc of the sun between them are
direct illusions to important festivals
of the first new moon of the year. And
there was everywhere an annual
celebration of the festival of the first
new moon when the year opened with soul
the sun and luna the moon in Taurus. And
the symbol of Taurus is that one over
there. The crescent and disc combined
always represent the conjunctive sun and
moon. That means basically the male
female deity male female aspect.
Well, it was worshiped as we see over
here adoration of the celested cow me.
There's the allseeing eye. Uh the eye of
Osiris. Here are the horns. There is the
disc in the horns and it also
represented the plunging of the sun god
into the womb of the mother to be born
by Isis. So the horns are also a
representation of the moon the sickle
moon. So in later religions or from
Babylon itself is Syrian style there you
have the half moon with a solar disc in
it and the same over here enlarged. Note
that this is Bal Hadanadan, the birth of
the sun. If we go to Mesopotamia, we'll
find the old symbol of Bal and Bell was
exactly the same. The half moon and the
star in it representing the birth of the
sun. Isis and Osiris, the male female
aspect. So this would be Ashtoret
and Tamuz or Isis and Horus. the male
female. The same you find in Egyptian as
we have already discussed it. This is
Baal worship. This is Lucifer worship in
his male female form.
Now the papacy has exactly the same
thing because the pope is today the
representative of the Babylonian
religion. So when he says the mass he
has a round wafer disc its roundness
coming as a symbol of Baal.
And after a mass it is placed in a
monstrance which is a half moon. So then
you have the birth of the sun and you
have it symbolized in this form. Here's
another monstrance in which the host is
placed representing the birth of the
sun. So Catholicism uses the symbol of
the half moon with the sun or the star
in it. Here's a Roman Catholic church in
Germany and it has this interesting
clock on it which I photographed.
There's the moon and there is the star.
And this particular star here has eight
points. And as this clock moves around,
of course, every time the long arm and
the short arm intercolate, you have the
birth of the sun god. baladad balhad
balhad every now and then every hour of
the day. Very interesting. So the symbol
of Catholicism
is the moon and the star hidden of
course in many other symbols as well. We
find Islamic symbols in the strangest
places. Let us go to the state of
Louisiana. And here's a police car of
New Orleans. And we see the Islamic
symbol on it. Here is the supervisor's
car. You can see it quite clearly. Now,
that would be all fine and well, but let
me take you to the church of the Lady of
Guatalupe in New Orleans. Here is the
symbol on the front of the altar. Here
is the typical cave where they have Mary
within the cave. Inside this little cave
chapel, you have Mary inside the grotto,
a typical pagan symbol with all the
notes of thanks for her intercessions.
And if we go inside this little church,
we have all kinds of interesting icons
and pictures.
And this sad picture over here of people
actually believing that there is merit
in touching one of these icons. If only
we could reach people and tell them that
Jesus is available everywhere in the
world and we can speak to him directly.
But why I'm taking you to this chapel is
not only to show you the Marian
idolatry, but to show you this stained
glass window where they have the Islamic
sign right there and to disguise it. Of
course, they say New Orleans City
Police. Now, what have the police got to
do with a place of worship? Surely, this
is just to bring this symbol in under a
pretext. Now, if you really use the
Islamic symbol correctly, you would have
to turn it round because the moon is a
representation
of the uterus upside down like the boat
mast situation. And here you can see it
perfectly. Well, if you do that, then of
course you have the goat of mendus. So
these Islamic symbols are found also in
Roman Catholic churches under various
disguises.
Now this ancient religion existed before
Islam and the initiates of this religion
as we saw in morals and dogma were the
insiders like Oregon for example and the
bishop of Alexandria these were the
initiates who harbored the ancient
religion and they were Christian
so-called but of course they were not
Christian they just propagated that for
the goyam
Catholicism,
true Christianity, they fought tooth and
nail and tried to eradicate and they
tried to eradicate the word of God as we
saw by changing it. Now Islam arrives on
the scene way after that. So the true
harborers were in Christianity before
they were in Islam and they were in two
places, Alexandria and Rome. Alexandria
was eventually taken over by
Christianity and the bastion the great
library was destroyed and the final seat
of the occult knowledge was in Rome. So
Rome is the seat of the ancient occult
knowledge before Islam even appeared on
the scene. That is the fact. And this
ancient occultism had a potent enemy.
Who was that enemy?
Christianity.
Christianity was growing in the place
where the disciples had taught it.
Christianity was growing in the hot land
of the Middle East, Asia Minor, all the
way up to India. The Bible says into the
north of Africa. That is where true
Christian
doctrine prevailed. They kept the
Sabbath. Only Alexandria and Rome did
not keep the Sabbath. Alexandria soon
disappeared as a seat and then the
Sabbath was not kept in Rome. Very
interesting history. So the symbol that
Catholicism uses is the star and the
sickle moon. And this star by the way is
exactly the same star as is used in
Islam. Isn't that interesting? I wonder
who gave rise to whom. Obviously the one
who is first can only give rise to the
one who comes second and not the one
second give rise to the one who comes
first. Isn't that correct? If we think
about it,
so in Catholicism we find the half moon
or the sickle moon where the deity is in
them. We find Mary replacing Jesus
Christ as the mediatrix of all graces.
The mediator, the sole mediator and
advocate is replaced by Mary. So here in
this Roman Catholic monastery, Christ
puts the crown of thorns onto Mary and
she has the holes in her hands.
Mary is always depicted as coming out of
a cave. Now, the ancient deities always
came out of a cave. Lyola the Jesuit
received all his information in a cave.
And it is interesting that Muhammad
received all of his information in a
cave. That's paganism. That has nothing
to do with Christianity. Now here we see
in Islamic countries in uh this
particular one over here
we have this strange structure over here
and we have a statue of Mary on top of
it and Mary there appeared apparently as
this little gazelle but before the king
shot it changed into Mary and she told
him to build a monastery and uh that she
did or that He did. And there is the
monastery high up on a hill. Now,
whenever I find a monastery high up on a
hill, I'm very interested because high
hills were pagan high places where they
sacrificed to pagan deities. It is
interesting that all the cathedrals in
the world are built on pagan places of
worship. Even the Vatican is built on a
pagan site of worship. Nothing has
changed. So when I came to this
particular place in the Middle East, I
went to look for the ancient place of
worship and sure enough on the hill
there it is the triple arches of the
ancient deity of sacrifice in the cave.
As per usual, it's interesting that Mary
always appears in the cave. In Fatima,
she's in the cave. In Lord, she's in the
cave. The pope is always visiting the
cave and worshiping in the cave.
As Osiris represented the sun in
Egyptian law, Isis represented the moon.
But the truth is that Osiris represented
the male active generative powers of
nature while Isis represented the female
passive or prolific powers. That's
encyclopedia of Freemasonry. So it's
actually a form of nature worship. These
these people would do well in the
Bohemian Grove worshiping the trees.
The Templar re revelation identifies
Isis as the black Madonna on no less
authority than a former head of the
priaryy of Zion. The black Madonna cult
is century to the priary of Zion. To
them at least there is no doubt about
the significance of the black Madonna.
You see Osiris was both black and he was
white and he's worshiped as black and he
has worshiped as white. Mary is
worshiped as a black Madonna and as a
white Madonna. So we have all these
interesting nuances. The Hittites use
the symbol of the half moon and uh the
solar deity. This symbol today of course
is used by none other than the United
Nations.
Well, let us travel to an Islamic
country today. Here is
a Catholic cathedral in Aman.
And uh I'm photographing this Catholic
Cathedral standing at the mosque. So I'm
standing on the ground of the mosque and
I'm photographing the Catholic cathedral
right opposite. Now it's interesting how
Catholicism and Islam stand side by side
in all the Islamic countries. And every
time I am so surprised to see the
cathedral and the mosque next to each
other. You see if you know the inside
religion behind the scenes they're
actually the same.
So if I look at the symbolism on the
outside of the Catholic cathedral, I
have the symbol of the sun because it
was the symbol of the sun worship and
the cross of course the symbol also of
the sun god. And there is the symbol of
the sun. If I go across the street and
there is the great Abdullah mosque, one
of the finest built by King Abdullah. On
the gates you have the symbols of the
sun. Same symbolism, same religion. on
top of course. Now here you have the
moon, the sickle moon which the Catholic
Church had on the clock. It was a symbol
of bale or bell.
Inside this mosque there are of course
no pews because in Islam you bow down
and kneel on the floor on the carpet.
And if you look up at the tremendous
dome you have again the great solar
blazers in this wonderful building.
Islamic dress. Well, you can look at
old-fashioned Catholic nuns and you will
find that the dress is identical.
Catholic nuns wear the same dress as
Islamic women of Orthodox faith. This is
uh the great mosque in Damascus.
Fascinatingly, inside the mosque, right
inside is the shrine. And there is a
Muslim man praying at the shrine. Now,
who's he praying to? Is it to Allah
there? No. He's worshiping a relic of
the dead because this is the shrine of
none other than John the Baptist.
Now, if you know something about
Yansenites, we've spoken about that.
Then you can already pick up if you pick
up the name John, you have Johanssonism,
then you have secret societies blended
in the background. And they claim that
this place has the head of John the
Baptist. So an Islamic
shrine
in Damascus. This is by the way the
oldest mosque, the most illustrious
in uh that country has this head.
Fortunately, the Roman Catholic Church
has a shrine with the arm of John the
Baptist. I always say if they carry on,
they might be able to put him together
again. I don't know. So it is the same
form behind the scenes inside the
mosque. The women are not that
important. They are relegated to the
side. The men get the central positions.
They are praying there with beads. In
Catholicism, you pray with beads. You
pray with rosaries.
And uh Islam is a very solemn religion.
Just some of the sounds in this great
mosque.
Now, which other religion has the
priesthood just for men?
The Roman Catholic Church. is exactly
the same. And here you have the same
position in the Islamic world. The
Islamic allseeing eye. This is a very
prominent structure that is used in all
of Islam. And you will not find a taxi
cab anywhere in Islamic countries that
will not have the allseeing eye there as
a protection. Of course, it's used in
Catholicism as well. And it's on the US
dollar and all these interesting places.
There's of course the eye of hat, the
eye of Osiris on an Egyptian temple.
There it is on a Roman Catholic pulpit.
Another one on a Roman Catholic
cathedral. Masonic author Carl Claudi
writes, "This is one of the oldest and
most widespread symbols denoting God. We
find it in Egypt. In India, the open eye
of Egypt represents Osiris. In India,
Sver is represented by an I. And the
Encyclopedia of Freemasonry says, "The
allseeing eye is an important symbol of
the supreme being borrowed by
Freemasonry from antiquity. On the same
principle, the Egyptian represented
Osiris."
So, Islam uses the symbol, Catholicism
uses the symbol. I'm just showing you
some comparisons. To the ancient
Egyptians, the right eye symbolized the
sun, the left eye the moon. So there you
have again the two aspects of the sun
god. Bailey then goes on to mention this
is Alice A. Bailey that the eye of God
is Shiva or Sa the destroyer. Remember
Shiva is the Indian god who is the
equivalent of Osiris. Shiva is also a
synonym for Satan.
Is it possible that both religions in
the inner circle worship the same
Lucifer, but that the outer court knows
nothing about this?
Well, who was Baal? Encyclopedia of
Freemasonry. Whenever the Israelites
made one of their almost periodical
deflections to idolatry, Baal seems to
have been their favorite idol entire
Bale was the son Ashet the Mune. And so
we have all the evidence that they know
exactly what they're doing.
There is no contradiction here for Set
is the Egyptian devil and Shiva is the
Indian god of destruction. Both names
Set and Shiva are listed in the Satanic
Bible as another name for Satan. And
Elena Petrovatzki affirms now we have to
remember that SA Shiva Palestinian Ba or
Malik and Saturn are identical. Is it
possible that both religions serve the
same master behind the scenes and that
the masses are deceived just like in
Catholicism? Beautiful people who are
kept ignorant and the sincerity of the
Muslim
duped and misused
because they are goyam catacumans.
Elena Petroatski links set to Satan.
Hermes the god of wisdom is called tat
tatet satan all of these ancient Egypt
Satan set was worshiped under obscene
homosexual rituals
and they had temples in which they had
these homosexual rituals for example the
lookor temple now I have lots of slides
of the look temple because I was there I
took many pictures at the looks temple
but I'm not going to show them to you
because they are pretty naughty Have you
ever been who's been to Luxor here?
Well, if you've been to Luxor and you go
to the one wall, you will see that the
fallus was very important and the
pictures are not for display. Uh I have
them, but I won't show them. Now, this
is an ancient pagan site, the Luxor
Temple, one of the great relics of past
times.
Now, here we're going into the entrance
and oops, what's that?
That's a mosque.
Now, where's that mosque built?
You You don't mean the mosque is built
into the Luxor temple? Is that possible?
Well, let's go a little bit closer. Yes,
there it is. It's in the Luxor temple.
What does that tell you?
If you had to build a Christian church
today, would you go and choose the
ancient pagan temple of Baal and build
your church right in it?
Yes or no?
>> No. Of course not. But what if the
secret religion is really the same old
ancient religion of Lucifer worship?
Would you then perhaps do it? Perhaps.
Yes. So there they've done it. It's
built into that temple. Amazing. On the
ruins. Now, let me take you to the
temple of Bell,
which is in another country in Lebanon.
And there it is. And on the bell site,
which is the same deity, by the way.
Oh, what is that? That is a Roman
Catholic place, a Roman Catholic church.
On the same site, there is the cross.
There's the temple of Bell. Why build it
on the same sites? Why have the same
rituals? Catholicism does it. Islam does
it. Do you think they have an agenda?
And if we go into the great Catholic
places, this is the place where Mary
apparently ascended. Here is the great
cathedral in Jerusalem. On the floor,
you have the solar circle with all the
signs of the zodiac, which by the way,
God forbids. God forbids. And this is
the place where Mary lay. And then she
ascended uh of course to heaven. She
didn't stay dead there on the floor. You
have the pagan symbols. You have all of
these interesting mitstoms and what have
you and the pentagrams, upside down
pentagrams, all symbols of Lucifer. And
then in the paintings, this interesting
star.
This is actually two squares, one inside
the other. And that is how the pagan
deities were represented very often,
either as triangles, one within the
other, or as squares, one within the
other. And the squares, one within the
other, were often used for Isis and
Osiris. There you see it in the Roman
Catholic Church dedicated to Mary.
Also on the floor of that Roman Catholic
Cathedral, you have the boat, you have
the waves, the water, you have the P and
the X. Remember that morals and dogma
told us that that was the staff of
Osiris.
So that means it's actually a male
phallic symbol and the boat would be the
womb. This is a very naughty picture in
a nice setting. Nobody would know what
that really means. Nobody would really
guess that that is an obscene picture
unless you read what the Masons say
about it. Now, isn't it interesting that
the ship with its mast in the half moon
was also the same depiction. So, here is
a Roman Cath Catholic cathedral built
like a Phoenician ship. Now, what has a
Phoenician ship got to do with Roman
Catholicism? Unless, of course, it is
the womb.
Now, let's ask Albert Pike to explain
this to us. Albert Pike writes that Isis
and Osiris, the active and passive
principles of the universe, were
commonly symbolized by the generative
parts of man and woman. The Indian
lignum was the union of both as were the
boat and mast and the point within the
circle. All of which express the same
philosophical idea of the union of the
two great causes of nature blah blah
blah blah. So we're still on track here.
We find this in the Roman Catholic
Church
inside this knight's temple. We've been
there before. But I want to show you
something else. Remember last time I
showed you the double-headed eagle, but
I'm now going to point your attention to
the floor. Oops. What is that? That's an
eight-pointed star. Now, who does the
star represent?
Well, there's the star of Islam. Isn't
that interesting? The two are identical.
There's the star of Islam in various
forms. So, we find the star of Islam. We
find it in the Catholic cathedrals. We
find it especially dedicated to Mary.
and we find it in the Islamic world.
Now, how does the star come into
existence? It's simply a square within a
square and there you have it. If you
want to have the star of David, you just
take the triangle within the triangle
and you have it. There you go. It's a
sex symbol. It's occult. It's very
occult, in fact.
So, now here's an interesting story of a
man who claims to have been a Jesuit.
His name is Alberto Rivera.
and he claimed that Cardinal the Jesuit
general personally instructed him on the
origin of Islam. According to Rivera,
now the Roman Catholic Church started
Islam on purpose to take the Arabs under
their control and to secure Jerusalem.
Fascinating.
This is of course highly ridiculed in
the literature. Nothing like that ever
happened.
But uh let me digress and speculate a
little bit. Who was first? Catholicism
or Islam?
Catholicism was first. And Catholicism
had a major problem.
You see, the Bzantine church initially
was on the side of Rome. No problem. In
fact, the Bzantine emperor elevated the
Roman pontiff to his level of corrector
of heresies of the entire world. So yes,
the Bzantine church and Rome were
initially one. Only after about a
thousand years did a split come between
the Orthodox and the Catholic Church
when the Orthodox patriarch refused to
accept and acknowledge the supremacy of
the bishop of Rome. And then war broke
out between these two groups and has
been waging since after the Russian
revolution. Now the Orthodox Church is
saying, "I'm sorry. I'm sorry." So
that's been resolved. But in the first
few hundred years of Catholicism's rule,
what was the main problem of
Catholicism?
Who was the problem?
The true Christians.
The true Christians. Because
Christianity had spread in the Middle
East.
Wouldn't it be nice if these supposed
Christians of Rome could use an
organization to eradicate Christianity
and replace it with another form of
their religion front organizations
they're very good at it you know the
Jesuits created who Freemasonry to do
the work if some then they ban
Freemasonry and if something happens
they say oh it wasn't us who was
freemason isn't that right or they blame
the Jews no it's not us who ruled the
It's the Jews, it's them, it's Zionism.
But in actual fact, it's Catholicism.
Now, if the occult world wanted to gain
control and the occult world controlled
Rome, why not control all occultism?
Wouldn't that be interesting? I'm just
speculating. I can't prove this. I'm
just saying that that's what Ria said.
Rivera said, nobody believes him. So,
let's have a look at what happens.
Fatima is a very interesting place
because Islam controlled Spain and
Portugal once upon a time and the pope
is here in front of the statue of
Fatima. There's the shrine, the Fatima
link. A Vatican insider Dr. Malachi
Martin has said that based on the
message of Mary in a personal
visitation, John Paul believes there
will come a day when the heart of Islam
already attuned to the figures of Christ
and of Christ's mother Mary will receive
the illumination. And I like these
words, you know, they they sort of ring
once you get to know them. It needs a
second Fatima in which they will
recognize him as God's vicar on earth.
So who must be recognized as God's
vicar?
The Pope must be recognized as God's
vicar. Then with fellow travelers like
the Church of England, the Episcopal
Church, and others of like mind, the
Pope could be woripped as the infallible
holy father by over one half of the
world's population.
I'd like to correct him. All of the
world's population, but that's besides
the point. Now, early Islam, which area
did it occupy? This area. This area. Who
ruled over here?
Who ruled there?
Only Christianity.
Before there was Islam, that is where
Christianity was. And so Islam took hold
of this area. Then by AD 750, Islam
progressed and took over all this
including Spain.
That's fascinating.
Spain. And all this Asia Minor area was
controlled by Islam. Did you know who
ruled in Spain? It was the Visigoths.
And the Visigoths had a different gospel
to Catholicism. They were more in line
with the Ostrogoths who actually were
Sabbathke keepers. Problem people that
had to get sorted out there maybe for a
while. Just speculating.
AD 900. There they go. Withdrawing from
the north of Spain. The Franks were very
strong Catholic supporters. Slowly
slowly Islam is moving out. And here
this whole area controlled now by Islam.
1,100
the in the south of Spain. In the south
there's a group which is more
independent than in the north.
Tremendous battle the Spanish area. Then
they control this area and AD 1,500
they're out of Spain. The west
Roman Empire is totally Catholic. This
is Catholic and Rome controls the
Catholic world and Islam controls this
area.
Today this is the Islamic distribution
and there are two uh sects the Sunni and
the Shia and they control vast areas a
huge area but initially where
Christianity was today you can put
Islam.
There's an interesting story that some
say that the red fears comes from having
dipped the blood into the Christians
having dipped the fairs into the
Christian blood at fairs. Whether that
is true or not, I would not wish to
speculate, but it's interesting.
Gary H remember speaks of the ancient
mystery religion controlled by
Freemasonry and the Illuminati and the
World Council of Churches. Now, what if
the true mystics behind the scene, the
power mongers are really in Rome and
that they control everything, including
this other religion through insiders.
And then if you put all the pieces
together with all the references that
there are, there are tremendous links
between the Templars and the Islamic
secret societies, the Ismiles, the
Karmatites, the Fatimites, the Drewzers,
and the Assassins. Now, the assassins
were interesting because they would kill
themselves to gain an advantage. They
could blow themselves up. Blow
themselves up to destroy others. Do we
have something like that today?
>> Oh yes. So nothing's changed. History is
repeating itself. Now who were these
secret societies that were in cahoots
with the Templars? Or did the Templars
control them? Who knows?
Let's read about the assassins. Degrees
of the assassins was thus as follows.
First, there was the Grandmaster known
as Shik al- Yabal or old man of the
mountain. Second, the Dal Kerb, the
Grand Prios. Third, the fully initiated
dasforce, the rashs, the associates.
Fifth, the fadis, the voted. Six, the
lassiks or law brothers. And lastly, the
common people who were to be simply
blind instruments. Does it sound
familiar? The poor blind goams
katakumans. Designs against religion
were of course not admitted by the
order. Strict uniformity to Islam was
demanded from all the lower rank of
uninitiated.
But the adept was taught to see through
the deception of faith and works. So
here we have a whole nations
subject to these insiders
using them as human cattle. Wouldn't you
feel sorry for them? Like we have to
feel sorry for ourselves because we've
been duped like that as well.
Thus, by the lure of paradise, the
assassins enlisted instruments for their
criminal work and established a system
of organized murder on the basis of
religious fervor. Nothing is true and
all is allowed was the ground of their
secret doctrine. The Jesuits have the
same doctrine today, whichever being
imparted, but to a few and concealed
under the veil of the utmost aerial
religionism and piety restrain the mind
under the yoke of blind obedience.
poor people duped by satanic insiders.
Now the Fatimmites was another group
that took over. The founder of the
Fatima dynasty of the Khalifas was
Ubadala known as Madi. Societies of
wisdom were instituted in Cairo. the Dul
Kimat or the house of knowledge by the
six Khalifa Hakim who was raised to a
deity after his death and is worshiped
to this day by the duses under the
direction of this man. The grand lodge
of Cairo was formed by the Fatimites and
continued the plan of Abdullah and there
were a number of degrees nine in all.
their method of enlisting procelites and
systems of initiation blah blah blah are
absolutely those which vice used for the
Illuminati. So you know there's no
difference between Rome and these folks.
It's the same organization.
Is it possible that they've used thesis
and anti-thesis for [sighs] thousands of
years if you like to rub up the remnants
of Christianity and opposition? And
later when the Orthodox Church split,
what did they do? They created an empire
called the Ottoman Empire which went in
and slaughtered the Serbs who were
Orthodox and slaughtered the Romanians
who were Orthodox. They raped the women.
They threw the children in the air. They
caught them on the ends of their
bayonets. They decimated whole Orthodox
areas. Incredible. And what escaped to
the north into Russia, it didn't escape
the sword of communism, Lenon and his
murderous band. There has been a
religious war since Christ died. And who
is being rubbed up the souls of men? So
here are the men of Islam. Who are these
insiders? Who are these
Ayatollas? Should the world be afraid?
The world is meant to be afraid. Are you
with me? So you have thesis, you have
anti-thesis. In the world wars, they
said communism is the threat. You are
supposed to be afraid so that you will
accept any changes that are necessary to
meet the threat. Now they're using this
as the next threat to create the
synthesis that they want. They're going
to rub up two religions against each
other. Christianity, Judea, Christian
culture, Islamic culture, rub them up
and and destroy each other until what is
left?
Synthesis. And then you have one world
religion and Lucifer rejoices because
he's king. Isn't that what Albert Pike
said what he was going to do? Wow. So,
who are these so-called men of Islam?
Well, I had this man down on the screen
long before he was fingered as a 33
degree Freemason. I said he was going to
be super terrorist number one and
they'll probably never catch him. They
haven't got him today. Who knows if he's
still alive. We'll talk about him
tomorrow.
The Bible is an indispensable part of
the furniture of a Christian lodge. You
remember this text? I showed it to you
earlier. comes from morals and dogma
only because it is the sacred book of
sacred book of the Christian religion.
The Hebrew pentatuk in a Hebrew lodge
and the Quran in a muhamadan one belong
on the altar and one of these and the
square and the compass properly
understood are the great lights by which
a mason must walk and work.
Which one? Obviously not the Bible
because morals and dogma itself says it
hates that Bible. Didn't it say that? We
read the quotes and they changed it all
and the Hebrew pentat well that is the
Bible. So which one is left?
Which one's left by elimination? The
Quran is left. Now the Quran as such or
rightly understood?
Probably rightly understood. Why?
Because the Quran directly
demotes Jesus Christ.
It's the book that directly demotes
Jesus Christ. Whereas the others had to
be modified to just to the insider to
demote Jesus Christ. Are you with me?
Now let's have a look at this. This gets
fascinating. The deadly deception. James
D. Shaw was a 33 degree Freemason
and uh he was at an interesting ceremony
where a very high preacher very
prominent preacher his first name is
Billy by the way was also there at his
initiation ceremony but that's another
story 33rd degree Knights commander of
court of honor past worshipful master
blue lodge past master of all Scottish
rights bodies that's what he was he was
a 33 degree Freemason and he explained
some of the enrich rituals. The deadly
deception, James D. Shaw, 33rd degree
initiation ceremony. The oath is sealed
by drinking wine out of a human skull.
May this wine I now drink become a
dearly poison to me as the hemlock juice
drunk by Socrates. Should I ever
knowingly or willfully violate the same.
We've done this before. I'm just
bringing it to perspective. A member
dressed as a skeleton places his arms
around the candidate who then states,
"And may these colds arms forever
encircle me should I ever knowingly or
willfully violate the same." So that's
the 33 degree initiation ceremony.
But there is another one. Each of us was
presented along with a Scottish right
ring a copy of Albert Pike's book morals
and dogma. So you get that when you get
to the 33rd degree. We were told that it
was the source book for Freemasonry and
its meaning. We were also told that it
must never leave our possessions and
that arrangements must be made so that
upon our deaths it would be returned to
the Scottish right. Fortunately, I
didn't have to go through the process.
But I have one. I have one. Very useful.
Now, what's this got to do with Islam?
Now, this is the highest degree of
Freemasonry. What happens there?
The deadly deception. The Scottish right
includes 29 degrees beyond the blue
lodge culminating in the 32nd. The York
right has the equivalent of 29 degrees
of the Scottish right in advancement
along the path that culminates in the
degree Knight's Templar. So the York
right culminates at Knight's Templar and
the other one is the 32nd degree in the
Scottish right. Okay. In addition, the
shrine
ancient Arabic order nobles of the
mystic shrine is available to 32nd
degree masons and knights templar who
wish to participate.
So the highest order is available.
Those of the highest order can become
shriners. Now the shriners on Arabic
order and this is for Protestants and
this is where the plot thickens. Do you
think there is a link between Shriner
Freemasonry and Islam, Christianity and
Islam? Well, I think there just might
be.
We were talking about Shrina Freemasonry
and how it links Islam to the secret
societies. Let's continue our
interesting little
investigative study. The shrine, the
ancient Arabic order, nobles of the
mystic shrine. The shrine is the show
army of masonry
maintains a very high profile. It is
necessary to be a 32nd degree mason for
6 months before being eligible to join
the shrine. Only the highest Freemasons
may join the shrine.
Now these are most of the prominent
Americans by the way. All the big
prominent Americans march through New
York as the shriners in their
masquerades. Now the shrine is in the
name of Allah. Did you know that? So
here the Christians of so-called
Christians of the 32nd degree who now
know already that they worship Lucifer
come to the shrine with a Quran on the
altar. Now the Bible's gone. When you
reach the highest level of Freemasonry
and you become a shriner, the Bible's
gone.
We sealed our solemn oath in the name of
Allah, the God of the Arab, the Muslim,
the Muhammad, and the God of our
fathers. Wow. Is Allah the God of our
fathers?
Here's the oath. In willful violation
whereof, I incur the fearful penalty of
having my eyeballs pierced to the center
with three-edged blade, my feet fllayed,
and I be forced to walk the hot sands
upon the sterile shores of the Red Sea
until the flaming sun shall strike me
with a livid plague. And may Allah the
God of Arab, Muslim and Muhammad and the
God of our fathers support me to the
entire fulfillment of the same. Can a
Christian make such a note? Yes or no?
Obviously not.
So masonry is nothing other than the
ancient mystery religion and Jesuits are
the ancient mystery religion and Islam
is the ancient mystery religion behind
the scenes. And who do you think
controls it all?
Rome. Rome controls it all. So, how
would you like kit if I said that I
believe that Islam and Catholicism
behind the scenes is one and the same
thing?
Have you noticed that Catholicism never
complains about Islam not allowing
evangelism
because it suits their purpose? It's
already Catholicism.
But when evangelism is done in
non-Islamic countries and it draws
Catholics away,
then you have huge drama. Isn't that
interesting? Those are double standards
which are hard to understand unless you
look behind the scenes where you have
all these Egyptian rooms and the Syrian
rooms. And here is a Masonic lodge, the
Freemason lodge meeting in Cairo.
President Gamal Abal Nasar, President
Nasar 1954 to7, Anvar Sadat 1970 to
1981. They were all members of the Aeo,
the ancient Egyptian order and of the
ANOS, the order Arabic nobles of the
mystic shrine. So, isn't it interesting
that they're all working together behind
the scenes? This is all a joke. Here is
judge Rakip Idris, ex-governor,
grandmaster of the sovereign grand
commander of Egypt. There is the fairs
as their symbol. This is uh a mason
himself who showed me in Lebanon that
most of the high Muslims were all
Masons. He himself was a highmason.
Anyway, masonry. Let's go to this
Masonic temple in Oklahoma. And what do
we see? Aha. We see affairs and we see
Arabic symbols
and we see affairs, affairs, affairs,
affairs. And of course, Muslah,
Muslim, Allah. So Freemasonry at the
highest level worships Allah who
actually directly is set
symbol of the the moon and the star.
Well, Arthur Edward Weight says Babel
represented a Masonic enterprise. Now
what does this mean? Now let's get a
little bit deeper into the story. We've
seen that before as well. The Tower of
Babel. Now that's what the Tower of
Babel looked like supposedly. Notice
that it is built as a sty sp spiral.
These are all the representations that
you find in the literature. There's
another representation of the tower of
babel. Notice the spiral way in which it
goes up to the top. There's a whole host
of them. Spiral, spiral, spiral,
circular. There's a strange one, but
they're all spirals. Most of them
probably look like that. So, that was a
masonic enterprise. Now,
isn't that interesting? Let's look at
this picture again. In an Islamic
country, Mary on the spiral standing on
top. Here we have Holy Mary, Queen,
circle with a dot in it. Do you remember
what Albert Pike said that was? That was
the generating principle like the ship
in the mosque. Same thing. They use that
symbol for Mary. Oh, here's another
place. Can you see that over there?
There she stands. This is in southern
Africa on the spiral. What is this?
That's the Tower of Babel. There we see
it from the front. This one over here in
Lebanon. I took this one myself in
Lebanon. There she is on top of the
Tower of Babel. So, who's going to be
queen of the new Babylon?
Mary. But who is Mary? Mary is Isis,
is she? Here is this church where her
figure is with this Phoenician ship over
there. There you can see her silhouette
through the window. And there's the
painting of her. She is the queen of
Babylon. Let's ask Blavatsky whether
this is so. Secret doctrine. It is
mankind which has become the serpent of
Genesis and thus causes daily and hourly
the fall of sin celestial virtue which
thus becomes the celestial version which
thus becomes mother of gods and devils
at one and the same time she is the ever
loving beneficient deity to all those
who stir her soul and heart. That's the
secret doctrine. She says Lucifer is
divine and terrestrial light, the Holy
Ghost and Satan at one in the same time.
So Satan, Mary, one in the same thing.
In Blavatsky's work, Isis unveiled. She
says Isis the Egyptian had the
following. Holy Isis, universal mother,
mother of gods, mother of Horus, Nate,
mother soul of the universe, virgin,
sacred earth, mother of all virtues,
illustrious Isis, mirror, justice,
sacred lotus, sister of aarta, baba,
moon, queen of heaven, model of all
mothers. Isis is a virgin mother. Then
she continues in Hinduism, same thing.
It's holy nari, Mariama. Interesting.
Mother of perpetual ficandity, mother of
the incarnate God, mother of Krishna,
eternal virginity. All the same features
all the way through. Then we go to Isis
Roman Catholic litany of the verses.
Same book. This is secret doctrine.
Uh at least Isis unveiled. Holy Mary,
mother of divine grace, mother of God,
mother of Christ, virgin of virgins,
morning star.
Very interesting. Mystical Rose, Queen
of Heaven. All the same titles.
Isis, Mary. Now notice, this is Isis
unveiled. This is Helena Petrovnllki
speaking herself when Sirill, the bishop
of Alexandria. Oh, well, what can you
expect? Of course, it was Alexandria had
openly embraced the cause of Isis, the
Egyptian goddess, and had
anthropomorphized her into Mary, the
mother of God. And the trinitarian
controversy had taken place from that
moment. The Egyptian doctrine of the
emanation of the creative god of mit
began to be tortured in a thousand ways
until the councils had agreed upon the
adoption of it as it now stands. So
there you have it. There it is. The
bishop of Alexandria
made Isis into Mary. So it's the same
old worship. So if you go into a Roman
Catholic cathedral or a Roman Marian
shrine, here I've photographed one in
Europe. This is recent. I took this
five weeks ago. This is brand new. It's
nice to have some new slide. Prayer to
the star of the sea. Oh Mary, star of
the sea. Who is the star of the sea? Who
was the god of the sea? Was Poseidon. It
was Osiris.
Oh dear mother, I now come to thee with
greatest confidence the many miracles
which had happened. Fill me, poor
sinner, blah blah blah. Thou, oh
sweetest mother, oh amiable star of the
sea, do not let me go away from here
without being heard, etc., etc. Thou
canst help me, for thou art mightiest
after God. I just put that in for the
goyam. They actually believe it is God.
Here's this famous pious, the same one
who catapulted Adolf Hitler to power.
1950 dogma of Mary's ascension to
heaven.
And uh here is the dogma. We declare
that the most blessed virgin Mary in the
first moment of her conception was by
the unique grace and privilege of God in
view of the merits of Jesus Christ, the
savior of human race, preserved intact
from all stain of original sin. Now this
doctrine is incredibly important because
now Jesus has his merits because of his
mother and not because of his father.
Remember that Jesus has the traits of
his mother. Can I burn that sentence
into your head? Jesus has the traits of
his mother. That's what this doctrine
teaches. I will give you the Protestant
preachers saying exactly the same.
Interesting.
Here focus magazine Mariain
Mary must become a goddess. Surely the
Catholic Church would not permit Mary to
be openly called goddess. Vipotite
female god. Absolutely. Why not?
Millions of us Catholics want a godly
Mary. Cardinal John O' Connor and also
Pope John Paul II, a great Marian
honorer are not averse to the idea.
There you go. Mary is God. Of course,
she's God to the insiders because she
is, as Blavatsky said, what? Lucifer.
She's Lucifer.
All right.
That's why in the King James version, we
read in Genesis 3:15, "And I will put
enmity between thee and the woman, and
between thy seed and her seed, and it
shall bruise thy head, and thou shalt
bruise his healed." Not even the RSV has
dared to change that. Genesis 3:15, I
will put enmity between you and the
woman, and between your seed and her
seed. He shall crush your head, and you
shall bruise his heel. But the Catholics
don't like it like that because the dua
rhymes online Bible which is the Jesuit
one says I will put enmities between
thee and the woman and thy seed and her
seed and she shall crush thy head and
thou shalt lie and wait for her heel. So
now Mary is the one who crushes Jesus.
It's the other way round. And now here's
a photograph of a Marian appearance in
Saiton Egypt. So the Muslims are looking
this and here's a fascinating book.
Queen of Rome, Queen of Islam, Queen of
all.
So, do we have the same religion here?
Let's just check this out. Let's take
the Roman Catholic website hearts uh are
Roman Catholic doctrine regarding web
Mary. This is their doctrine, not me
speaking. The one holy, catholic, and
apostolic church is led by the bishop of
Rome, successor to Peter, the first
pope, has always venerated the blessed
virgin Mary, including her sinlessness.
The church follows scripture, especially
the New Testaments, which she herself
compiled as perfectly as she follows her
tradition. For behold, henceforth all
generations shall call me blessed. Luke
1:48. Then this is still their their
papers. This is what the Catholics are
writing. It is no surprise that the
woman would triumph over the red dragon
for scripture says so at the very
beginning refer Genesis 3:15 which
states and all will establish a feud
between thee and the woman between thy
offspring and hers and she is to crush.
So which which one are they quoting?
Which one are they quoting? The Catholic
Jesuit one. Wow. Fascinating stuff.
Let's continue.
uh same web page to Mary the woman of
scripture and mother of men who keep the
commandments and hold fast to the truth
concerning Jesus. Oh, that's an
interesting statement. That comparison
will make such fun as we get a little
bit later into Revelation. The church
applies the beautiful words of wisdom.
She the glow that radiates from eternal
light. She the unarnished mirror of God.
Because Mary is full of grace, the
church through Pope Pas has declared her
as conceived immaculate without sin.
Very important.
Mary has become known as the immaculate
conception as a result of the apparition
of Lords in 1851.
She is immaculate. Jesus is sinless just
because of her, not because of God,
because of her.
The immaculate conception
or the immaculate heart. Catholic
encyclopedia book six makes it clear
that heart in the biblical sense means
the inner person. Therefore, the
Catholic Church says bishops united them
consecrate the world to the immaculate
heart. The whole world has been
consecrated to the immaculate heart. Now
that's fascinating. Let's read a little
bit on this exceptional importance is
further confirmed by Mary herself when
she appeared at Fatima. Now we have an
interesting link. You have seen hell.
Then come the visions. We've discussed
them. The vision of hell. Russia would
be consecrated. Uh Pope John Paul 2. She
didn't mentions his name but he's the
one who will suffer. So they said is the
third one. and all the world will be uh
dedicated to her immaculate heart. Mary
further proclaims that Russia will be
converted and then you have this whole
story. The world will be saved by Mary's
children, those who are devoted to her
immaculate heart. This is fascinating
stuff. Now let's read an article on the
same web page, Catholic web page by none
other than the famous Catholic bishop
Fulton Sheen and see if we can get
something from this. In an article, Mary
and the Muslims found in the Mincenti
report pages 1 to3. Cardinal Mincenti
foundation considers this exceptionally
important. The good bishop says the
Quran which is the Bible of the Muslims
has many passages concerning the blessed
virgin. First of all, first of all, the
Quran believes in her immaculate
conception
and also in her virgin birth. Her virgin
birth. Please note her virgin birth.
Have you got this? She was immaculately
conceived and the mother of Mary was
sterile. So who is now the savior
counterfeating Jesus Christ? This one.
What an affront. The third chapter of
Quran places the history of Mary's
family in a genealogy which goes back
through Abraham, Noah, and Adam. When
one compares the Quran's description of
the birth of Mary with the apocryphal
gospel,
who says the apocryphal gospels must be
accepted as canonical. Who says that?
The Vatican said that at Council of
Trent. Okay. The birth of Mary, one is
tempted to believe that Muhammad very
much depended upon the latter. You see,
Muhammad was married to a Roman Catholic
nun. The whole family was Roman Catholic
and he received his doctrine straight
from the pits of the bottomless pit.
That's what
the Bible says. So this doctrine started
spreading and they used Islam first to
counteract Christianity later on
splitting it up to get rid of the
enemies of Christ or to get rid of
Christ's followers and then to get rid
of all the enemies of Rome.
Both books describe the old age and the
divi definite sterility of the mother of
Mary. Isn't that fascinating stuff?
Joseph inquired how she conceived Jesus
without the father. Mary answered, "Do
you not know that God when he created
the wheat had no need of seed, etc." The
Quran has verses of the enunciation,
visitation, nativity. Angels are
pictured uh accompanying the blessed
mother and saying, "Oh Mary, God has
chosen you and purified you and elected
you above all the women of the earth."
Do you see the links? Who created who
did Catholicism create Islam or did
perhaps Islam you think create
Catholicism? Can't be because
Catholicism was there before Islam. Same
doctrine. There's such a strong defense
of the divinity of Mary here in the
Quran in the fourth book attributed to
the combination of the Jews to their
monstrous calm against the Virgin Mary.
Now it gets even more exciting.
So the bishop says the two largest
religions in the world believe in the
fervent devotion to Mary and hold her
virtues in very high esteem. And they
say the Muslims and the comp and the
Catholics comprise two billion people
together. Well, we're in control. And
all we need then is the Orthodox Church.
They also have this. It is true too that
there are large numbers of Protestants
who hold Mary in great favor. Give up
your religion, folks.
Join the club or else we'll see. The
great mother Terza made this point when
she summed up the matter in simple and
forthright words. No Mary, no Jesus.
Isn't that interesting?
Wow. Okay. So, recognition of the
immaculate conception by the world will
tend to bring a closer relationship
between the great Christian
denominations, Catholic and Orthodox, as
well as between Christianity and Islam.
So what is the syn synthesis? They want
a union of the religions. What does
Freemasonry teach? Well, Jesus, the son
of Joseph, the Lord, the Messiah, and
the apostles and after these Muhammad,
the son of Abdah with his law, which is
the law of Islam. And the disciples of
truth followed the law of Islam. The
what? The disciples of truth followed
Islam.
When Christianity had grown weak,
profitless and powerless, the Arab
restorer and iconclass came like a
cleansing hurricane.
Wow. The faith of the Arab had become
stronger than that of the Christian.
This is the true Christian. So Islam is
nothing else than Catholicism
winning over or defeating Christianity.
The Gnostics made a soul descend and and
ascend through eight heavens and each of
which were certain powers blah blah
blah. Morals and dogma. And then notice
what morals and dogma writes about. In
the ancient doctrine, certain geni
were charged with the duty of conducting
souls to the bodies destined to receive
them. Now, you've heard about the genie
in the bottle, haven't you? Arabian
knights rub the bottle and woohoo here
comes the genie. Now what are these
genie? Now notice that freemasonry
speaks about geni.
This is interesting. Gets exciting. I
love this detective work. It talks about
a familiar genius. So have you heard of
the word genius? Comes from geni.
Now who are these? These geni are the
media of communication between man and
the gods. Have you got that? This is
what morals and dogma freemasonry says.
The geni communicate between man and
God. The Jesus Christ of Islam is
different to the Jesus Christ of the
Bible. And we'll tell you why in a
moment.
1 John 22. Who is a liar? But he that
denth that Jesus is the Christ. He is
antichrist that denieth the father and
the son. We saw how the cath the
Catholic uh scholars changed the Bible
to remove Jesus as the sole savior. Now
let's look a little bit further. Let's
go to the Quran. Now it gets
tantalizingly interesting.
Here is the Quran. Salman Rushi remember
that affair when he wrote the satanic
verses. He said there were some strange
verses in the book and wow there was big
trouble on his head. He said
at least two early Muslim scholars Iben
Sad and an anonymous Persian historians
have related a legend which explains the
origin of a group of apparently
contradictory verses in the Quran. the
so-called satanic verses. Surah 53:19-20
reads, "Have you thought about also
to have interfered here with the
transmission of the holy word to
Muhammad and tricked him into saying,
"You can pray to these two." Later he
corrects it, but the seed has been
planted. And through the archangel
Gabriel, this was then corrected. That
was basically the story. Now, let me
take you to the Quran.
This is the Holy Quran with Arabic text
transliteration in Roman script by M.
Abdul Haleem. This is the International
Quran. This is not written about the
Quran. This is the real McCoy. I have
it. And this comes straight from the
explanation by the top theologians on
the Quran itself. This is the
international version that is used in
the United Nations. Let's see what it
says.
Revitalize humanism.
Islam is the message of the Quran. It is
perfect and a practical religion of
equality, liberty, and fraternity. Where
have you heard those words before?
French Revolution
submission to the supreme being. Islam
also insists upon the fundamental unity
of all revealed religions in origin.
That's what Freemasonry also teaches.
Then they have a section which says with
spirits there has always been a class
generally called rationalists mainly
including philosophers and scientists
who doubt now deny the existence of
association speaking with a spirit.
While on the other hand those usually
called spiritualists mostly including
saints and sants and psychics feel sure
of spirits and spiritual experience. At
one time or other much fraud was
practiced in the name of spiritualism
and etc etc. But the Quran affirms the
reality and approach between the two old
parties is already in sight. So the
Quran says spiritualism is fine. What
does the Bible say?
It's satanic. Leave it alone.
Angels.
Angels have their own shapes usually
carrying wings. They are formed of
light. They are capable of easy
transformation. That gives a whole
description of angels.
Angels particularly approach people at
the time of their death with good or bad
tidings according to the situations.
They descend. Fear ye not nor grieve.
And they quotes the Quran. Smite their
faces and their backs. They descend with
blessings etc etc. And there's another
class of beings. What's that?
Geni. Now where did we read about them?
In Freemasonry.
Next to angels come geni
who are formed by fire. The well-known
elatan.
This stands straight in this Quran being
the head of this creation. They had
close contact with the prophet Solomon.
So in other words, Satan is the head of
the geni and the geniuses are the ones
like Plato and the others and then you
get devils. These are the bad guys.
So geni are not bad and Satan is their
head. Is that not interesting? In the
Quran, it would appear from the Quran
that man is superior to the angels and
the geni. They make themselves perfect.
Then they talk about six day periods and
they talk that we came into existence
through evolution.
And now let's see about the doctrine of
Jesus Christ. This is where we're
heading and of Christ in the Bible and
the Quran. But the Quran says Christ was
altogether saved from the indignity of
the cross. Christ never died on the
cross. That's what the Quran teaches.
Who also teaches that?
Spiritualists. The insiders. Because
Christ, remember, didn't die for you.
Did you see that? H taught the same
thing who translated or created the
Greek text for the modern Bibles. He
said the same thing that
Christ was spared. And as if by a
miracle of likeness, someone else of the
same features was crucified by the Jews
under illusion.
says the Quran verse 157. And they Jews
said and boast we killed Christ Jesus
the son of Mary the apostles of God in
the knowledge of God but they killed him
not nor crucified him but it was made to
appear to them and those who differ
therein are full of doubts with no
certain knowledge but only conjectures
to follow for assurityity they killed
him not. What does that say? Jesus did
not die for you.
This is satanic occult teaching.
Verse 158. Nay, God raised him up unto
himself and God is mighty wise and there
is none of the people of the book but
must believe in him before his death. So
the Quran is directly against Jesus
Christ and the insiders in the western
world are directly against Jesus Christ
and so the Jesuits.
While the Jews claim to have killed
Christ on the cross, it is also a
cardinal point of faith to the Orthodox
Christian churches that Jesus Christ
gave of his life on the cross. He was
buried after crucifixion on the third
day he rose again. Blah blah blah that
he met his disciples and was afterwards
taken up bodily to heaven. In fact, this
is the belief which formed the basis of
the theological doctrine of blood
sacrifice,
vicarious atonement for sins, which is
our ever losing its force with the
modern age and age of action and
retribution. Isn't that what Hort said?
Yes or no? Is there a difference between
the Catholic theologians and Islam? Yes
or no? None whatsoever. Who is
controlling who? God is indignant says
the Quran explanation here. God is
indignant if Christ is believed to be
God himself.
Christ is not even the son of God
but only an apostle like several others.
The same hatred for Jesus Christ comes
out over here as we saw the theologians
influenced by the Jesuits reveal.
Now this is a tremendous quote from the
book home missionary. I like this quote.
The Savior has said, "He that believeth
on the Son has everlasting life,
and he that believeth not the Son shall
not see life, but the wroth of God
abideth on him." He says again, "And
this is life eternal, that they might
know thee, the only true God, and Jesus
Christ, whom thou hast sent."
Muhammadanism
has its converts in many lands and its
advocates deny the divinity of Christ.
Shall this faith be propagated and the
advocates of truth fail to manifest
manifest intense zeal to overthrow the
error and teach men of the preexistence
of the only savior of the world?
So basically what I'm doing is I'm
showing intense zeal to overthrow the
error and to show you that it is a lie.
Oh, how we need men who will search and
believe the word of God, who will
present Jesus to the world in his divine
and human nature, declaring with power
and in demonstration of the spirit that
there is none other name under heaven
given amongst men whereby you may be
saved. Oh, how we need believers who
will now present Christ in life and
character, who will hold him up before
the world as the brightness of the
father's glory, proclaiming that God is
love.
I spoke to one Muslim I iman who convert
converted to Christianity
and I said to him my friend what is the
difference that you have found between
your previous Allah and Jesus Christ and
he said the only difference between the
two is for God so loved the world that
he gave his only begotten son that
whosoever
believeth in him should not perish. That
is the difference. Allah, a god of war,
a god of retribution,
a god that sends his people into
destruction, promising them celestial
virgins on the other side and eternal
bliss and hell on earth and hell in
heaven for all women.
and Jesus Christ who says we are all
equal before God. Nobody has the right
to submerge the other's character in
himself. You are free agents before
Jesus Christ.
Yes. It says wives submit to your
husband
as in the Lord. Husbands love your wife
as the Lord loves his church. My Jesus
is my husband in that allegory if you
like. He's never forced me to do
anything. Never ever has Jesus forced me
to do anything. Anything I do for Jesus
Christ, I do because I want to do it. If
I want to say to him, "Goodbye. I'm
off." Will he stop me? Will lightning
come from heaven and I'll go sizzle
fits?
No.
Jesus is the most fantastic
being in the universe. Gives you
absolute freedom of choice. Allows you
to choose for him or against him. And
the only thing he has in his defense is
when I be lifted up, I will draw all men
to me. Love is the character of God. And
love is the only thing that may conquer
otherwise we will have perpetual hell.
I was asked once by someone by well I
won't say he asked me BUT WHAT IF THE
OTHER SIDE WINS? Won't you come over?
What a strange question.
I said you know I've read the last
chapter Jesus wins.
But even if you were right, even if the
other side wins, let me tell you
something. I'd rather be dead.
I'd rather be dead than live a life of
perpetual hell under a control freak
who has fascism as his government and
has puppets who do his will and his
bidding. And those that do his bidding,
he showers with whatever earthly junk he
can give them. But love
which comes from freedom of choice, he's
incapable of giving. He hasn't got the
power to give it. He's nothing to give.
He's bankrupt. If Jesus Christ is not
victor, we might as well be dust.
But thank God Jesus is going to be
victor. This is the message for our
time. The encyclopedia bratannica says
de deviations in the Quran from the
biblical narrative are very marked and
can in most cases be traced back to the
legendary anecdotes of the Jewish Hagada
and the apocryphal gospels. Who controls
those secret writings? Rome controls
them today. Rome says you must believe
them. the Jewish Cabala, the Zohar, the
Zepherets,
those are the ones and we find uh
writings of Abraham and all of these
supposed writings. Well, the Zepha Zets
is also said to be the work referred to
in the Quran under the name of the book
of Abraham. These are the occult
writings that create these books.
the coming of the redeemer. What does
the cababala and all these say? The abom
abominal columnies on Christ and
Christianity occur not only in the
cabala but in the early additions of the
Talmud in it. It says about Jesus that
one such a one a fool a leper a deceiver
of Israel. All these terrible words
about Jesus Christ.
What's this slide doing here?
the pope and actor Jim Cavisel who acted
the part of the Christ in the movie the
passion of Christ kneeling down before
the pope
isn't the pope papacy uplifting Jesus
Christ here isn't it
well if you watch carefully Mary is the
one who receives a lot of attention
Peter kneels down and asks Mary for
forgiveness
Yes, if they were to come straight out,
nobody would believe. But what if you
present a gospel for the goyam
and you attract them into this religious
net which at its core is a lie?
What about poor Islam? What about
exactly the same thing? The outer core
is taught Islam with the most rigorous
exacting things that these poor people
have to do on a daily basis.
And the insiders don't even believe it.
They worship Lucifer direct and they're
the most lentious of all people.
Millions of people being deceived in the
world. Isn't that a catastrophe?
Should we not stand up and say God is
love? Give your lives to him and split
with these lies that are being taught in
Catholicism and Islam and in Hinduism
and in Buddhism. In Buddhism, you sit
and you empty yourself until there's
nothing left. And then you start
levitating because you are weightless.
You have become nothing.
Jesus Christ says, "I have come to give
you life to the full. I will fill you
with myself."
And what do all these other religions
do? They empty you until you are a shell
and there's nothing left of you.
What a terrible deception.
and all these exacting rules and
rituals.
It is terrible to to not have Jesus
Christ and the freedom that we have in
him. Look at this.
This is the truth behind the scenes
here. You have rock stars bowing down
before the pope. You have Yasa Arafats
kissing the ro Pope's ring.
Protestant preachers, what do they say
on the issue? Well, let's listen to May
30, 1997 on the David Frost program.
Billy Graham said, "I think Islam is
misunderstood, too, because Muhammad has
a great respect for Jesus." Ha. Has he
read what they say?
And he called Jesus the greatest of the
prophets except himself, man, exalting
himself above the Son of God. And I
think that we're closer to Islam than we
really think we are. Billy Graham,
aren't you speaking Masonic language?
What about Robert Schuler? Did an
interview with Larry King referring to a
meeting with a grand mufty? Schuler
bragged, "I have seldom met with a man
whom I felt an immediate kinship of
spirit and an agreement of faith and
philosophy quite like I have with the
grand muty of the Muslim faith." What
are these Protestant preachers doing?
Larry King live interview with Robert
Schuler Christmas Eve 1999. King asking
why he met the Grand Mufty and why are
you here? The idea of bringing religions
together, right? Absolutely, says
Schula. We are in totally new era. The
age of being able to indoctrinate people
is finished. King, does this visit
Robert Schuler give you encouragement,
Schuler? Oh, absolutely. The Grant Mufty
said, "Religion is like rain that falls.
The extremists
pollute the pure water."
I predict we're going to focus in the
next millennium as religious leaders to
clean up the pollution in religion.
Wow. I think those that don't want to go
along with the synthesis, the pain of
the separateness is going to become so
great
that the troublers of Israel. Those who
say there is no other name under heaven
and earth whereby you can be saved,
they're going to be in trouble. Maybe
this is the last time you will hear a
message like this. Who knows? Take note.
Benjamin Chavis, he was the former vice
president of the National Council of
Churches. What did he have to say? He
stated that his ministry has always been
ecumenical and interfaith. There's a
link between Judaism, Christianity, and
Islam. And I believe that there should
be a great trial, not dialogue,
but a trialogue between these three
great revealed religions. In 1997, he
announced his converting to Islam and
becoming a member of Reverend Louis
Faran's nation of Islam.
He claimed that he still believes in
Jesus Christ, but he expects his
announcement to shock many of the
Christian friends and fellow members of
the clergy. And then he goes on to say,
he also insists that it really hasn't
changed. Nothing's changed. He states,
"If you pour water from one glass to
another glass, the composition of the
water is the same. I am who I am." No
difference between Islam and
Christianity. Of course, if you're an
insider, there won't be a difference
because you're both worshiping at the
same same shrine. The God of Judaism is
the God of Christianity is the God of
Islam. Sorry, not in my case.
My God
died for me.
They say he didn't die for me. They've
got a different one. What's that? The
Pope kissing the Quran. Yes. Here's the
photo of the pope at the end of the
audience with the patriarch Rafael of
Iraq where the pope bowed to the Muslim
holy book the Quran presented to him by
the delegation.
Of course
I have numerous slides for you where the
Islamics come and bow down before the
pope. Catholicism
from the beginning has controlled Islam.
Islam is just a tool of esoterics
to indoctrinate people into accepting a
synthesis.
And we are right at the end of time.
Revelation 18:4. And I heard another
voice from heaven saying, "Come out of
her, my people, that you be not
partakers of her sins, and that you
receive not of her plagues." I believe
there are many many people in Islam who
will see the light who will see that
they have been deceived just as there
are many many Catholics who will see the
light that they have been deceived. I
myself was a Roman Catholic. Here I am a
living witness to this fact and the
truth has set me free.
What a privilege it is for me to pray to
my Lord direct. What a privilege it is
to me to walk with him on a daily basis,
to experience him, to know that he
exists, to talk to him, to walk with
him, and away with all these rituals
that mean absolutely nothing but
bondage.
As for me and my household,
I would serve the Lord and I would
appeal to every Christian to follow the
word and do what it says and then none
of us will be lost. Thank you very much.
>> [music]
>> Heat. Heat.
Heat. Heat.
[music]
>> [music]
>> Hey. [music]
Hey. Hey. [music]
Heat. Heat.
[music]
Heat.
Heat. Heat.
[music]
>> [music]